there is a story a little bit saucy a
little bit spicy for this show even
though we're a family show so i'm going
to try to keep it clean the prime
minister of
finland
is a
well
i think the technical phrase would be
super hot young woman and the prime
minister her name is
sana marin
has
created a number of tabloid scandals
because she keeps getting out getting
caught going out and partying and
dancing and staying up really late now
their video's going around of her
dancing with some guy real close real
intimates he seems to be sort of
nibbling on her uh the guy is not her
husband
if if you haven't seen the video take a
listen
so all right that guy's getting real
friendly with
the prime minister of finland
all i keep thinking is could you imagine
biden doing this like our head of state
i wouldn't i wouldn't like
did you imagine the two of them together
i guess he would mostly be smelling her
hair so she's there at
santa marin is at this club she's
dancing then there's another video
that's been going viral of her kind of
dancing jiggling provocatively with a
bunch of girlfriends at some house party
they're all singing along to club music
and jumping up and down and
strutting about and
there's some guys there okay you get the
idea this is the kind of thing
this is the kind of thing
that
18 year olds do
it's the kind of thing that even in your
20s you do this okay
it's not what you expect from the prime
minister of a country and i don't i
don't want to be the fun police i really
don't
but my reaction to this
some people have said good for her you
go girl yeah and
that's the kind of lib perspective
and then
you know you get the sort of apolitical
perspective of hey if she wants to do it
what's the big deal who cares you know
and then a lot of other people are just
noticing that
she's a very good-looking woman and if
she were not a good-looking woman it
probably wouldn't be as cute
people wouldn't find it as charming as
they do because of this lady my reaction
to it though is
grow up
lady
grow up i'm not really even knocking
this kind of thing when you're in your
20s
when you're single
when you're in college
when you're i'm not knocking that all
right it's fun it's fun going to parties
fun dancing around i assume all the
people in those videos were
had had a couple coca-colas all right
that's that but
there's a time for every purpose under
heaven there's a time to go clubbing and
a time to refrain from the clubbing and
when you're 36 and you're married with a
kid and you're the prime minister of a
country
probably you shouldn't do that
she got in trouble too
this was a little while ago
a year or so ago at least at least eight
or nine months ago when the prime
minister lady goes out to a club on
saturday after her foreign minister had
tested positive and she was told for uh
kovid then she was told she did not need
to isolate because she was vaccinated
but then she got a text reminding her
that the vaccine
doesn't really do all that much and so
she uh she was they told her you got to
come home you got to isolate but she
didn't do that because she missed the
text because she left her phone at the
office and she was just out clubbing all
night and i just think lady grow up this
is a problem
for really the whole millennial
generation of which she and i are both
apart
which is
we don't want to grow up
we all just want to remain in perpetual
adolescence
this is why millennials use the term
adulting say wow i was adulting to i
paid my bills i was adulting
so that's unusual
i guess it is unusual these days but it
shouldn't be and you shouldn't be
boasting about how you're doing adult
things at 35 years old
you should just do them
but they want to put off everything they
want to put off getting married they
want to put off having kids when they do
get married and have kids they want to
put off or just neglect entirely the
obligations that come with that
they want to but they just don't want to
put it off and that's not good that's
not a good way to live
okay that that will fade the fun will
fade even looks will fade
got it should be doing the right thing
in the meantime right now go to epic
will.com use code knowles the left's
persistent and loud attack on truth is
aimed directly at your children the
public school system mainstream kids
entertainment social platforms seemingly
all of our country's cultural
institutions have been infiltrated by
the left's not-so-secret agenda their
words not mine to indoctrinate your kids
with weird sex stuff and anti-religious
ideologies and anti-american views and
marxism and socialism and all the rest
of it there are a lot of ways you can
protect your kids from these not so
secret agendas you can homeschool you
can get them involved in your church but
one of the easiest and simplest ways to
protect your kids is to take five
minutes tonight write a will with epic
will you can do it it's an online
platform it costs less than your next
trip to target they can set you up with
a will in as little as five minutes
starting at just 119 bucks plus you can
save 10 percent when you go to epic
will.com use code knowles k w l e s take
five minutes tonight write a will
ensuring that your kids will be raised
the way you intend
in the event that something happens to
you epicwheel.com use my code knowles
today i'm so glad you like those clips
now ring the bell subscribe we're going
to get a billion subscribers we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you